il semblait former le couple idéal mais
alors qu'il voyageait à travers les
États-Unis elle a disparu dans des
circonstances mystérieuses voici
l'histoire de Gaby Petito victime d'un
féminicide
nous sommes le 2 juillet 2021 un an jour
pour jour après leur fiançailles Gabriel
Petito 22 ans et Bryan Landry 23 ans
partent en voyage dans un van qu'il
vienne d'aménager pour l'occasion
sur les réseaux sociaux elle poste déjà
pas mal de choses en expliquant qu'elle
est passionnée d'art de yoga de nature
Gaby et Brian souhaitent découvrir les
grands espaces américains après avoir
traversé le Kansas et le Colorado ils
atteignent lutins où ils campent dans un
parc national
sur son compte Instagram Gaby Petito
partage tous les jours des photos de
leur voyage
mais soudain à partir du 1er août les
publications s'arrêtent
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ni Gaby ni Bryan ne souhaite engager de
poursuites l'un envers l'autre la police
laisse le couple repartir libre mais ils
doivent passer la nuit séparément Brian
dort à l'hôtel tandis que Gaby reste
dans le van
le 12 août Gaby Petito poste de nouveau
sur son compte Instagram mais cette fois
contrairement à ses habitudes le lieu
n'est pas tagué
[Musique]
quelques jours plus tard le couple
publie la seule et unique vidéo de leur
chaîne Youtube Gaby et Bryan les débuts
de notre voyage en vanne
[Musique]
le 30 août la mère de Gaby Petito reçoit
un message de sa fille
[Musique]
le parc national du Yosemite est situé à
plus de 1300 kilomètres de là où le
couple est supposé être
sans nouvelle après ce dernier message
suspicieux les parents signalent la
disparition de leur fille à la police le
11 septembre
[Musique]
alors que la disparition de Gaby Petito
fait la une des médias les internautes
jouent les enquêteurs et scrutent les
indices pour retrouver sa trace sur
Facebook et redit des communautés de
centaines de milliers de personnes se
partagent quotidiennement les dernières
informations comme il y avait toutes ces
publications qu'elle avait mis sur les
réseaux sociaux il y avait
plein de potentiels indices et ça a
poussé les gens à essayer de chercher
dans chaque photo de regarder l'endroit
où ils étaient de regarder sur Google
Maps
location
et même mise en ligne afin de retracer
les différentes étapes du voyage du
couple depuis leur départ
lui est rentré chez ses parents en
Floride seul avec le van ce qui est
étrange c'est qui refuse de parler il
refuse d'expliquer ou Gaby Petito et ce
qui lui est arrivé les personnes qui
suivaient vraiment la faire sur TikTok
sur Instagram qui postait tout le temps
là-dessus arrêtez pas de demander mais
que fait la police pourquoi est-ce qu'il
arrête pas quand est-ce qu'il va parler
Brian Landry et sa famille se mur dans
le silence et communique seulement via
leur avocat
[Musique]
alors que les recherches s'accélèrent
dans le Wyoming pour retrouver la jeune
fille la pression s'intensifie sur Brian
Landry et sa famille
le 15 septembre Brian Landry est
finalement déclaré personne d'intérêt
pour l'enquête deux jours plus tard ses
parents appellent la police pour
signaler sa disparition ils affirment
l'avoir vu pour la dernière fois le 13
septembre alors qu'il partait camper
dans une réserve marécageuse abritant
des serpents et des alligators
affirment avoir croisé Brian Landry au
moment de la disparition supposée de sa
fiancée
et ça avait One Piece
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
autour de l'affaire petite eau soulève
également des critiques certains
observateurs dénoncent la disproportion
du traitement médiatique alors que
chaque année 600 000 personnes sont
déclarées disparues aux États-Unis
à l'époque c'est que le fait qu'elle
soit une jeune femme blanche aisée qui
correspond aux critère de beauté
dominant ça avait forcément aussi aidée
stories
cette vidéo surveillance d'un
supermarché du Wyoming datant du 27 août
montre les dernières images de Gaby
Petito vivante
ce même jour une famille de passage au
parc de Gran téton filme le van blanc
sur le bas-côté d'une route le 19
septembre le corps de Gaby Petito sera
retrouvé non loin du véhicule
le 20 octobre des restes humains
correspondants à Brian Landry sont
retrouvés dans un marécage en Floride à
proximité les enquêteurs découvrent un
sac à dos ainsi qu'un carnet
[Musique]
dans le sac à dos du jeune homme la
police trouve également une lettre
écrite par la mère de Brian Landry avec
la mention brûlée après lecture
mes parents de Gaby Petito ont porté
plainte contre la police de l'Utah pour
négligence ayant entraîné la mort suite
à l'interpellation sans conséquence du
couple quelques jours avant la
disparition de leur fille
il poursuivent également les parents de
Brian Landry qu'ils accusent d'avoir été
au courant du meurtre et d'avoir aidé
leur fils à prendre la fuite